I think it depends on how you define
whether the survival if it's based on
yet just getting things done absolutely
but if it's based on having emotional
kind of security I don't think anybody
can I don't think he or any human can
literally live a happy life if they
don't have a connection with the
opposite or somebody that's a female
point of view like because because
there's a whole group of men that are
walking away from relationships it's
called mgtow and a lot of the like
no no no that's the difference but men
is men going their own way they're
walking away from relationships because
they just don't think women bring much
to the table anymore